taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste the
buddies
are back joe and sal it's taste buds
what's up taste buddies
oh boy oh boy how you doing we got a
banger today
today is this is what we call a banger i
think people are very opinionated on
these
i think people have a clear-cut favorite
i think some people would also
dislike them and be vocal about it i
think we have a pretty polarizing
match-up today
i agree some people would call these
beverages
breakfast beverages yeah some people
would call them
nighttime beverages after dinner
beverages
after dinner beverage 100 dessert not
not dessert beverage meaning a dessert
drink but something you have with
dessert yeah both of them both of them
play those roles i
will say though and we're not saying who
we choose yet but
t does have a sleep time component to it
whereas coffee
you stay away from it at all costs in
your bedtime for the most part
yes uh unless well you can have some
decaf right
oh yeah but who's doing that so you
think people pound decaf right before
bed
i think i think people have a meal you
know something like that i think plenty
of people after dinner
or you know you stop into a diner after
a show whatever it is yeah are going to
get a cup of decaf
because they enjoy the flav yeah
decaf coffee um can it
in your opinion and from your experience
and knowledge
can it muster up the bold flavor that
people are accustomed
what happens when you decaffeinate the
beans or when
like do you lose any of the flavor
profile or
or is there a decaf coffee that is just
as rich and good and
and deserving uh of of of the accolades
as
a regular cause i would think that it
must lose something because when you
look at the selection of decaffeinated
coffee it's a far
far smaller selection and not just
because well it's
less of a market share a lot of people
that drink coffee
well yeah but i would say too i would
think that there would be
some you know uh plenty of people drink
tea for the caffeine too
and you've got plenty of decaffeinated
flavors of teas
uh i i don't know and maybe there are
many decaffeinated flavors of coffees
but i've noticed when i go to the
supermarket if you look in the coffee
section
you're decaffeinated you're there's like
one or two yeah they're not
versus dozens of regular coffees so i'm
assuming something must happen but there
is way more decaffeinated tea yeah
i've i've noticed well because there's
more like
well there's sleepy time t there's more
bedtime related tea
products i've seen than uh
and also too tea is good for you when
you're sick
so you'll find the caffeinated teas that
are sick related because you know
they've got uh
ginseng in the er they're not
well something they got something in
them pimp i don't remember
but you know the point is is they have
plenty of teas that you should drink
when you're sick
that don't have caffeine you know
because you don't want to be all hopped
up with the flu
i didn't realize how you decaffeinate
coffee or tea
there are several ways to decaffeinate
coffee but the most prevalent is to soak
them in a solvent
did you know that i mean i never really
crossed my mind but i didn't think it
would be soaking them in a solvent
usually methylene chloride
or ethyl acetate neither sounds
healthy caffeine is then drawn out by
the solvent
solvent is a fun word to say
but i don't know if i want solvent
mingling with my beans
uh the answer to is the decaffeination
process safe
the answer is yes it is well i mean i
hope so
who knew is decaf coffee bad for you
though because it's the only thing
that's frowned upon in coffee the
caffeine
so does in essence decaf coffee take
care of that
uh it's the caffeine but also too
drinking copious amounts of coffee is
not great for you wait
you know why is decaf coffee good for
you
drinking decaf coffee has also been
linked with a small but significant
reduction of reduction
in the risk of premature death as well
as death from stroke or heart disease
very small a small but significant well
which one is it
well you you i think you could be small
and significant
you know you have coffee can you go up a
second decaf coffee may reduce the risk
of developing type 2 diabetes
that's interesting decaffeinated coffee
or decaf is similar in taste
and appearance to regular coffee but
contains very little caffeine there is
no evidence to suggest that drinking
decaf is bad for a person's health
it may even share some health benefits
of regular coffee
i know drinking regular coffee is in in
technical sense good for you
i think drinking incredible amounts of
it is very bad for you
i would think is coffee good for you not
only can your daily cup of joe help you
feel more energized
burn fat improve physical performance it
may also lower your risk
of several conditions such as type 2
diabetes cancer and alzheimer's and
parkinson's disease
in fact coffee may even boost longevity
did not know any of that
yeah yeah i uh i cut back on coffee
recently and i have noticed a difference
i've noticed a change
there is something about your
overall energy through the day meaning
you drag more
yeah that's not as good but i also
notice it makes me drink way more water
which is good
let's put tea up to the same test please
numerous studies have shown that a
variety of teas may boost your immune
system
fight off inflammation even ward off
cancer
and heart disease while some brews
provide more health
advantages than others there is plenty
of evidence that
regularly drinking tea can have a
lasting impact
on your wellness what we're gathering
here is both seem to have some benefits
positive benefits and not too many
negatives no yeah
um now that's i'm assuming they get
addicted to coffee and they have to wean
off of it
where they got the shakes and the
headaches and they they need it or they
crash
and so i don't you know that's that's
not i mean well i
i mean i think you've got to be in
pretty bad shape to be getting the
shakes from a lack of kids
people that are like don't talk to me
before i had my coffee like the people
that are in the morning though like i
need my goddamn coffee or i can't
function
uh well look it's a shot in your ass
it'll wake you up you know
but uh i don't think that's a terrible
thing i think that that's just i think
that's way more of a brain habit than
anything else
but here's some fun little facts yeah
i'd read them
real quick yeah i think this is all
based on the assumption that you're
drinking the tea and the coffee straight
that you're not dumping for sure sugar
or splenda or cream or milk we're
talking about it
i mean make it however you like it but
uh tea bags
uh on your eyes can reduce swelling and
puffiness
uh two steep
tea bags in your eyes can reduce the
dreaded dark circles
puffy right eyes and soothe your face
you can bathe in tea
it actually works uh bathing in green
tea can help detoxify and soothe your
sin
skin give it a try oh i'd like to take a
tea bath
[Music]
wouldn't you i mean yeah something about
a sentence
felt weird but um i guess i would
yeah coffee predominates in the americas
and in continental europe while t is
preferred in most of asia and former
soviet union
aggregating data on 79 countries uh
coffee and tea blocks coffee
predominates wow
in the americas i we i think we already
knew that going in
the coffee craze in the united states is
at critical mass
and tea of course uh let's see when did
coffee
where did coffee come from originally i
read the last couple you do it babe
uh the original domesticated coffee
plant is said to have been from harar
and the native population is thought to
be derived
from ethiopia that makes sense uh with
distinct
nearby populations in sudan and kenya
coffee was primarily
consumed in the islamic world where it
originated
uh what year we i mean is it is it like
this is going to rock your world as far
as what year
i don't know like dinosaurs were
drinking tea 15th century
oh maybe i'm wrong the earliest credible
evidence
of coffee drinking or knowledge of the
coffee tree appears middle of the 15th
century
in yemen i think these are both like
land before
time level you know
i think ancient [ __ ] there third century
so just about 1800 years earlier wow
that is wow incredible record of
drinking a medical text written
uh it first became known to western
civilization
through portuguese priests and merchants
in china during the 16th century
so western civilization actually came a
little bit after
1200 years earlier third century oad i
thought i said bc
my bad that's okay i'll let it slide
coffee influenced the course of history
salt once people figured wait the salt
what why is that
i don't know what that means the salt
once people figured out how to roast the
seeds of the coffee plant in the 1400s
coffee took over the world in doing so
it fueled creativity revolutions
new business measures literature music
it was like the first
slavery jesus christ what it started
everything
it was like the first cocaine yeah like
people drink coffee
it fueled creativity revolutions and new
business adventures literature and music
just down coughing you want to start a
small wheel business
but i mean look the t's no slouch you
had the boston tea party
right that was a big right sure that i
know all about that one
t met sugar forming a power couple that
altered history
uh t also feel one of the worst blights
on human history the slave trade so both
of these
were responsible well you got a product
all the way back then i mean how people
you know i guess
all right so we're going 3rd century
versus 15th century most of these things
most of the
qualities of these drinks both are
beneficial
much more so than detrimental very few
cut
setbacks uh mostly pros
uh to drinking either these beverages
plain of course
uh they fall during the same meals as
we've learned
decaf versions of each are safe
let's talk about who took which let's
talk about who took
which now why would you pick tea other
than to get completely pummeled
on this today um i began drinking coffee
later in life
i was never addicted to coffee i enjoy
it
um i like a strong bitter darker roast
uh uh the lighter roast although i
hear the lighter roasts are more
caffeinated um
but i was never i can appreciate coffee
i didn't have it until like my 20s and i
didn't really start drinking until like
the last
maybe five ish plus years where i have
it i'll always have it after a great
meal i'll have like a cappuccino or an
espresso or something like that
um but like a coffee midday sometimes
when we're filming i do it because
gato drinks coffee like five cups a day
and
he'll send he'll send out for it and so
like sometimes i'll just like tag on
but tea i've had from a very young age
uh i associate it with
like you know my mom used to give me
like tea and like not crackers but like
cookies i always like dunking in tea and
like whenever i had a cold
i always had tea if it was a sore throat
sure
my my grandparents i used to live with
them they always gave me tea
i found it weird growing up for me and
tell me if you uh you agree with this
but
i don't know if it was a stigma or it's
true
and we're just out of control now but at
what age do you feel
a child or a person can start drinking
coffee
and it not be frowned upon any age like
i know like
my friend my friend was uh he was first
genera uh
when you what is it when you're first
generation second generation italian
parents are from italy right
uh yeah so my friend a lot of my second
generation italian friends
coffee was very prevalent in their lives
as children even like they would have
like
like my my grandparents same thing that
they did like they were like butter
bread and like dip it in their coffee
you know what i mean and my friends did
that and i it blew my mind because
again coffee to me was an adult thing
like you heard it like sanka or my gran
my grandfather used to roast that uh
that juan vale that that uh was it
boosta
that really strong yellow coffee i know
what you're talking about
yeah yeah i know what you're talking
about yeah it comes in the yellow
yellow pack yeah yeah stella i like that
stuff that [ __ ] is strong
um it's espresso ground cover but i i
never really dabbled like
now and again we might do a starbucks
versus
duncan episode which we think would be a
powerhouse fight but i think because of
the boom in the united states about what
coffee is and how they
they mask it with with pumps of caramel
and macchiatos and fraps and whipped
cream and
i can't be bothered with any of it all
that but that's how they get the kids in
and now the kids are hooked on caffeine
and sugar my nieces are
14 and 16 they just turned 14 and 16.
they've been drinking coffee for a few
years each
it always blows my balls off because i'm
like you have no business drinking
coffee that's insane
and then i think people my family told
me i'm crazy that's an antiquated notion
i don't agree i i think coffee before
the age of 16 is nuts
it is right i think it's nuts but and i
think it's
i think the only way to appreciate it
before oh you're talking about having
the palette for it
well no no no i'm saying no no no no no
i'm saying give a ten-year-old kid i'm
saying no it's wrong i think
yeah because of what coffee is meant to
do for you
but also i think that the palette of a
child
under 16 or 17 usually on average
is not any this is it is the palette
that somebody of somebody that's not
going to appreciate it unless it's got
sugar and a ton of [ __ ] dumped into it
right and now you're drinking something
that's just as sugary as soda uh and
even more caffeinated
it's an epidemic even potentially more
serious for a moment here
you know i i don't get it a kid drinking
coffee is odd to me i don't understand
and i don't approve of your family quite
frankly
major health organizations like the
american academy of pediatrics suggests
children under the age of 12 should not
eat or drink any caffeine containing
food or drinks
older than 12 caffeine intake should
fall in a range of no more than 85 to
100 milligrams a day
uh what's in a cup of coffee 200 tea
and also which is stronger and i believe
it might be
tea's much stronger yeah but that's
weird because i don't hear
don't give kids tea very happy to say
that our podcast is being sponsored
still by better help
great service from great people they're
there to help you with
whatever that thing that might be
interfering with your happiness is
whatever that thing that might be
preventing you from achieving your goals
uh you know look in all seriousness we
joke a lot on this show
i have spent many years battling a lot
of these things
and i have yet to see a service that is
so accessible
and so fast and so user-friendly like
better health i'm not sure i really know
anything like it
because it it's not like one of these
crisis hotlines
it's actually connecting you with
professional licensed therapists that
suit your needs
within under 48 hours online you're
getting professional counseling
basically
at your fingertips which i i don't know
i really i i don't know who else is
doing something like well and also too
and it's about time i mean it's
it's it's why for so long has therapy
only been you have to get up you have to
get in the car you have to drive to the
office you have to sit down with the
person
you have to figure out if they're taking
new patients you have to do it's
so much crap that gets in the way of you
being able to help yourself
in a way that should honestly be as
convenient as being able to get
a pain relief pill it is and you can log
on to your account anytime that's number
one number two
it's worldwide uh there's a ton of
reviews on the site
go on click on one read what people say
about it it's at betterhelp.com
reviews and visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds that's betterhelp help
and join a million people who have taken
charge of their mental health mental
health
uh with an experienced professional
don't just bounce something off your
dumb ass friends
they're not licensed they're not
professional they're not going to give
you
the expertise you need you want to
take our special offer as a taste buds
listener and get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
tastebuds i want to talk about grammarly
an online writing assistant
and the reason i want to talk about it
is because i do a lot of writing
and when you're writing it's little
things that are going to trip you up
it's
little dumb mistakes it's it's having to
go back and recheck things it's having
to go back and proofread it's not
catching something
and those mistakes can not only take up
your day uh they can also be
very embarrassing given that proofread
hit send and then hate yourself for a
couple hours after that
yeah it's brutal it's brutal so
grammarly has offered this great free
service that will check things like uh
spelling errors
in real time in real time but they now
have grammarly premium which is going to
give you real-time suggestions on your
writing
so you can get to your next item on your
list in record time and what i mean by
that
is they're going to give you clarity
suggestions so you can get your message
across
quickly more clearly not using
unnecessary words less redundancies uh
they search for
they replace overused words which is i
think is
if you're looking to at least improve
your vocabulary maybe in a work setting
if you're sending a work email
because you could do it on you know on
your desktop and stuff but you could
also do it uh with texts
and things like that it's pretty cool if
you want to just make sure you sound
more professional it's like you're
having someone proofread
you're also getting vocabulary
suggestions no more searching for
synonyms
uh grammarly premium will offer
suggestions to over to replace overused
words and phrases
i can't tell you how helpful that is and
how often i'm going to thesaurus.com to
look up words that i'm not thinking of
or whatever
so you can use it on your phone you can
use it on your favorite browser you can
use it
seamlessly with microsoft office that
helps uh
so get yourself into some grammarly all
right
so get yourself into some grammarly you
won't be sorry
hit send with confidence and get your
point across more effectively
with grammarly premium get 20 off of
grammarly premium by
signing up at grammarly.com tastebuds
i'm going to spell that for you
it's 20 off that's great it's
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
that's grammarly dot-com taste buds
well here's the thing eight ounce cup of
cough 95 so they're saying a kid over
a kid just over 12 could have a cup of
coffee a day and it's not too bad for
you here's the thing
here's the thing with tea and this has
always been my problem with tea i like
tea
uh i associate it far
too closely to being sick
and to bedtime to ever want to drink it
regularly i just don't want to drink it
regularly
and i think tea is the liquid of the
gods i mean the monks have it
i i i'm not feeling it man and i find
and i i will say this too
drinking let's just say right now joe
has chosen coffee and i have chosen tea
i thought we said it earlier i don't
believe that we did it no i did i said
why would you choose t
other than to get completely popular i
thought that was a question you were
posturing
in general oh no you chose t that's
right and you will be
just a boy your boy chose t but
i'll put iced tea up against iced coffee
any day though yeah i mean what do we
take
that's a different you know that's a
different argument and what but but all
it is that's
all it is though if we're talking pure
on pure you make coffee and you put ice
in it you make tea you put it i tell you
this
i'm taking this coffee boo i'll tell you
this
i'll tell you this plain tea which is
the only way i drink it
versus plain coffee which is the only
way i drink it
it just can't even hold a candle to it
like tea
needs sugar it needs honey
i don't agree it needs something man
what about all the varieties of teas
i mean coffee have different roasts sure
but they're all kind of
i mean you might have notes of one might
have done notes of
you know whatever all the different
notes coffee has i get it
but just as varied are the breadth of
tea options you have at any given
restaurant anytime they bring over a
beautiful
chest it looks like the ark of the
covenant they open that [ __ ] up
and there's everything from citrus teas
to mint teas to chamomile teas to earl
greys
it's a breakfast tea it's a it's a it's
a high noon tea
to put you to bed tea it's if you don't
feel well tea they got
throat coat they got all they got
everything you can imagine it's just
right there just right there what you
just said
throat coat it just sounds like hospital
drink
but what i'm saying is there's you know
for every need and desire
there's a tea for every meal there's a
tea for every hour of the day and
there's a tea for every function it
promotes immunity and health
it helps you when you're sick it warms
you up okay it's good for dunking and
eating
you could have it with a nice toast yeah
yeah you can have it with all kinds of
things
but that doesn't speak to my point i
think tea is more versatile plain tea
you throw some ice in it you have it
with a sandwich chips plain tea
flavor you know an unsweetened iced tea
is a real letdown as much as i do i mean
what are we talking about here it can be
what are we talking about here
nobody likes the unsweetened better than
the the
no i only drink unsweetened that's all i
drink too because i have to
but you tell me there's only because i
want to no [ __ ]
you tell me there's a snapple on that
table versus an unsweetened tea you're
grabbing the unsweetened tea
i will not drink a snapple regular i
will not why
i i've weaned off of like sugar like
that like i'm not
saying i'm not i i understand i'm not
saying
what you do because you do it because
she's gonna raise he's better blind
the one with the poison in it yes
exactly exactly
uh whereas i actually believe that
coffee black
tastes better than coffee with sugar and
a bunch of [ __ ] dumped in
i will give you the fact that a black
coffee
tastes better and
for people who drink coffee a black
coffee with nothing in it and no sugar
i think the people would enjoy more than
your average person that you know what i
don't know what i'm trying to say
exactly neither do i
i was agreeing with you but as i'm as
i'm going through it i don't necessarily
agree
i think if you're a tea person you'll
take down sweet and tea if you're a
coffee person
you'll take them on sweet uh of course
you'll take it but i'm saying who
is who is kicking back maybe a lot of
people
i don't know i but i i cool reflections
i'm getting glass of iced tea by the
pool
we already did iced tea versus lemonade
babe we don't need to go down that road
again
i know but iced coffee is nowhere near
okay but
you know we're not talking the ice
versions of these drinks we're talking
the hots
we're talking about we didn't this thing
was shot in the polls all right okay all
right but i think people know
coffee nobody nobody's arguing from the
standpoint of iced coffee
shout out lisa gale coffee tea or be
with me look it up all right
fair enough uh love you elise anyway
this is my point i know a lot of people
as you know yeah i know a lot of people
so yeah you know you know people i know
a lot of people
i know a lot of people that don't drink
coffee
the number one way i would describe you
for people like you know joe derosa
what's he like and i
and i say well taste something right now
he knows people thank you
i don't know man i i'd be hard-pressed
right now to think of one person i know
that sits down and gets excited
about dunking a tea bag into hot water
and just drinking it plain i don't know
i never see i don't know if i've seen
anybody i know do that
without adding something else to it
that's all i do
when i've never seen you do that might
do it you do it in secret cause it's
shameful
no i do it all the time as a matter of
fact room service in hotels
i always get tea because they give you a
little pot they usually wrap it in a
little saran wrap so it stays hot for a
couple hours
and i like going back to it they do that
with coffee
they bring a pot of coffee to your room
nothing feels more manly
than a pot of coffee showing up at your
door on a little silver platter
one of those ceramics cups
let's take let's let's let's navigate
through that entire sentiment
he said nothing feels more manly which i
so there's nothing else more manly than
this is what you're saying i'm saying
for me said nothing feels more manly
i mean you could throw a hatchet at a
tree split it in half no coffee
at the door okay old school you
a bear with a bow and arrow you could
you know hang glide off a mountain
into a ravine i got it you could box
someone in a championship fight
right you could uh join manly
i don't know anything
that aluminum nothing feels well man
that aluminum i'm just getting a pot of
coffee
delivered yes to your room on a nice
cute little silver tray
yeah yeah why i like a silver tray
that's my business
okay okay maybe i don't go by the
standard definition of what a man is
nothing is more manly but my point is
you pick up that silver thermos thing
with the black plastic head on it
yeah and you poured into that white
ceramic cup i mean you're dabney coleman
babe
it's like yeah you're an old school dude
it's great
i don't know i i picture tea
relating to sages and wise men
i pictured t uh okay i pictured tea
relating back to the ancient ruins to to
the people that built our societies
they drank tea they drank tea to calm
themselves to enlighten themselves to
boost their immunity
i just feel like tea is just a while
it's i feel like
it's it's i connected to
wise smart people that helped build
the earth coffee houses that stretched
across the arab world and eventually
europe became not only the internet of
their day
spreading gossip and news but also
centers of discussion that fostered
important
cultural political and scientific
information i'm glad you point this out
pam
because that's something no because
that's something that
yeah and i'm gonna say it nobody's ever
said this
let's go discuss occupy wall street over
a cup of tea
are you insane are you let's go discuss
the election over a cup of tea can just
go
just google high tea and let him read
what comes up hey let's go
t let's go to the google it hey i have
to work on my screenplays
i have to work on my screenplay i'm
going to the tea shop yeah
now what is high tea okay
it's a cultural cornerstone and just as
i just related t
to the wise old sage up in the
himalayans i also relate t
to the little beautiful burgeoning young
girl who is playing with her dolls
and it's fostering her creativity and
they're all sitting around having a
little tea party
right from from a young age
to an older age boy i never hear people
like i can't drink tea i'm addicted to
the caffeine
even though it why is that why don't
people because especially if tea has
more caffeine in it
why is it not an issue like coffee it
sounds like it is you're talking about
getting your
pots delivered to your room and going
back to it you wrap it in saran wrap
you might have an a t addiction you
don't even know it you know you know you
know uh you know what you could also get
at every single coffee house where all
that's going on
tea yeah but they're not called tea
houses are they
they're not no but there's a reason for
that with all their variety and all
their [ __ ]
they're not dedicated stores i go into
stores that have aisles and aisles
will you weigh the t now there are
stores dedicated to dildos what does
that mean right
there's a store for everything you're
looking for out there i don't know i'm
talking about popularity i feel like
there's be a deal this would be a
component of a story we wonder what the
hell are we talking
about i got a shop in my neighborhood
that just sells
cooking herbs but it's insane why but
why is it
why is it that coffee houses exist
and not tea houses is it because selfie
is
culture i think that it's marketing i
think that
they realize somewhere about 20 years
ago these sons of [ __ ] and
by the way shout out to t keeping it
real
charging what should be charged for a
cup of tea
you put the bag in no matter what it is
it's a couple of bucks
tea didn't lose their mind he hasn't
gone off the deep end
they tasted a little bit of fame and
money and then all of a sudden their
their heads exploded he's not
an egomaniac coffee people were like
there's coffee
you could you come dare you you should
have coffee in new york coffee
you got a cup of coffee 65 cents it gave
you a shot in the chops you needed
and you went about your day coffee was
associated with coins
someone realized you can just say this
is fancy coffee you get
six bucks for it pump it full of sugar
and there was a revolution
don't go to those places no but i'm
saying like what
who does coffee think coffee is oh i'll
tell you who coffee is
coffee is beans baby no coffees of it
everywhere it's my turn it's my turn
coffee is the drink of the working man
you're sitting here saying
who does coffee think it is you're
bringing up aristocrats you're bringing
up
monks you're bringing up sages with tea
coffee let me tell you let me tell you
who you
hear when you think of coffee dirty
harry clint eastwood cop on the job
what do you think about fire drinking
great wall of china hold on 14
000 miles long took thousands of years i
guarantee you all those mofos were
sipping on that
all right that's fine that's fine but my
point is my point is
coffee is the drink is a corner so drink
of america
comedians and cars i'm going daddy
you get coffee uh uh what's the other
place it's not denny's the other the
other uh
uh diners
ihop coffee what's the other one pimp
the other diners don't need to sit here
and listen to those the other chicks
named chains let's let's
it's the car it's a cornerstone of life
that tea is not
let's talk about coffee and
entertainment oh
frasier where'd they hang out every day
the coffee shop
oh seinfeld the greatest sick of all
time where'd they hang out
the coffee shop oh friends where did
they hang out the coffee shop
never saw tea is a cornerstone of any
city every one of those every shop has
tea available
they never drank it though because it's
coffee is a lifestyle drink tea is not
he has been one of the most popular
commodities in the world over
centuries profits from its growth and
sales funded wars and
fueled colonization and its cultivation
brought about
massive changes in land use labor
systems
market practices forget slavery social
hierarchy don't forget slavery
the effects of which are even uh with us
even today
okay how t-shaped the modern world
can you click on that right there how
did t influence the modern world
no that's small print i'm not gonna do
that oh yeah that sounds like an
interesting book
yeah it sounds riveting doesn't it on
wikipedia tea
culture i got to tell you learning a
second language was the hardest thing i
ever did in my academic career
say something to me in another language
right now me gusta hugara volleyball
that's all i remember from spanish what
is that
i like to play volleyball oh you said
volleyball i know what you said
uh well listen to me now you got babble
yes
which is the number one selling learning
language app
i love it it's i use it on the go i they
have 15 minute lessons uh
that they specify it's fun too it's not
boring
they make it like a fun way to learn
practical
real world conversations in mind and
that's still one thing i don't get from
i used to carry uh in school but also i
live with my my my grandpa i used to
carry a little
spanish to english dictionary which is
fine for looking up words and brushing
up a vocabulary but it doesn't
teach you and it doesn't teach your mind
how to conversationally speak
and i always thought there was a big
leap from learning the vocab
to being conversational and i think this
bridges that gap i love that about babel
yeah i really love that about babble
hence me only remembering the volleyball
thing from spanish
plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps to improve your
pronunciation and accent that's another
thing you don't have that like
you know in school you have to listen
everyone reading they're like uno
necesito
like it's like okay you gotta yeah i
don't know if uno necesito means
anything but i don't know
who knows i i
right now when you purchase a three
month babel subscription okay you're
gonna get an additional three months
free so six months
for the price of three at babel.com you
gotta use our promo code tastebuds so
babble let me spell it for you
that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code taste buds for an extra three
months free babble
language for life let's talk bare bottom
folks i'll tell you what
i got two bags of stuff that i ordered
here and
i have been wearing i i've almost worn
everything
in like the two weeks straight that i've
had it yeah because
it's like that beautiful medium ground
between like
dressing up and like also just like
being able to just go anywhere with it i
love something that's ok
because because i'm a single man oh you
need a versatile piece of garment
exactly because you don't want to show
up on a date going i'm trying too hard
or
hey lady i don't care right neither of
you want to show up where she goes he's
just right we're talking the third ball
porridge babe yeah you want to go from
the gym where you're bench pressing all
sorts of pounds
that's right and you want to be able to
skirt right over there to lunch at a
nice outdoor cafe where you zip your
coffee this is what i'm saying and i
love
bare bottom slacks i said it before i'll
say it again
internet's best deal is coming from
these guys just got those bad bottom
slags
boots with the furs this is they got the
best deal on high quality and versatile
menswear plus they got ten thousand
five star reviews which doesn't hurt uh
and i like that they're giving back
too that's part of what the company does
bare bottom has donated over
a hundred thousand pairs of shorts to
children in need
and they're gonna start this summer with
uh donating a school lunch for each item
why doesn't every clothing company do
that can we all do that
we should all i mean why do they have to
be i mean bare bottom is the only people
doing this yeah so support bare bottom
right now our listeners get free
shipping off their first order
right now our listeners get free
shipping off their first order of these
super comfortable threads where they
gotta go joe where they gotta go
bearbottomclothing.com
use that promo code tastebuds that's
barebottomclothing.com
spelled b-e-a-r like the animal
animalbottomclothing.com and use the
promo code tastebuds
get yourself some free shipping tea
culture is defined by the way tea
is made and consumed by the way that
people interact with it and the
aesthetics around
oh what about that t t has
a whole breath of products
based around tea tea cups and sauces and
tea kettles
so we're coffee cups and coffee
i mean but i'm saying it's like a
cultural thing it is
so is coffee there's a very there's
coffee there's an aesthetic around tea
my friend here's something nobody ever
said after a dinner party
should i put some tea on what do you
know
no after every dinner party who throw a
pot should i put coffee on that
coffee that's because we're coffee
that's because people need it
to not fall asleep at the dinner table
if they get the itis you want car
why cheese got more caffeine i have tea
babe he's got more caffeine i have teeth
oh look who it is
the johnson stuff uh we weren't
expecting that get out the coffee cake
you got the tea cake the coffee cake you
don't think people say i'll throw on a
pot of tea
sal never once there it is in history
here it is
we want you guys to email us at info
tastebudspod.com to tell us what you
want on your merch
and i'm telling you if we don't see over
and over and over
joe deroser saying statements like never
once have i heard
never once in history you know what you
never hear
you speak like that and every time you
do yourself in a service buddy
people put on whenever all the time when
have you seen
when have you seen 10 people at a dinner
table and somebody throws on a teapot
antioxidants let's talk them let's talk
them right now
coffee has its advantages but tea wins
in the war of antioxidants
while green tea is most commonly
associated with antioxidants
white tea actually contains more oh
i mean coffee and donuts every point you
make about tea is nerd [ __ ] what do you
mean
it's like oh you know the monks up in
the mountains they they put their sheets
on and then they drink tea
and they talk about antioxidants and
healing who gives a [ __ ]
talk talk to me about let's go get some
donuts and
coffee he is distinguished and talk
about the cake talk about
right you lean on coffee and americans
americans are just running around they
run on dunk and they're shoving [ __ ]
into their mouths they're overweight
they need to be picked up they need to
be let back down
six styles for a cup i need my cup of
coffee they smell like i'm gonna shut
breath i'm gonna t is tea is i'm gonna
shut your tea is like
i'm gonna shut it's time to have a
little bit of teeth i'm gonna shut it
like this i'd leave a pinky up i'm gonna
you drink coffee like that
[ __ ] pinky no because i'm not an
aristocat like i'm a
like just i'm a gentleman no that's such
a gentleman
you look like a gentleman drinking you
look like a coffee bastard
i've been watching a lot of game of
thrones listen to me wait wait wait wait
wait
wait now i have a candidate coffee can
cause you to
over produce your own digestive acids
and create problems such as upset
stomach to ulcers
yeah yeah because he doesn't leave you
crashing that can keep going we can keep
going
maybe the ulcers maybe the ulcers come
from the job the man is on when he's
drinking the coffee
like solving a murder after another
murder after another murder
kojak yeah that's right maybe that's
what the officers come from
you're making fun of me because i got
people in the himalayas sipping on
i'm gonna shut down the biggest ruins
i'm gonna shut down your whole thing
right now ready
ready ready yeah ready yeah ready i mean
how many times
do you want me to say yeah one more yes
tea england coffee
italy captioning case
[Music]
and have an available versus versus
a good day mate you got some biscuits we
can eat
at 3 p.m with our coffee
with our tea you idiot or tea sorry
i pic you know what i picture t a
construction site worker with the
mustache the size of a walrus who's two
steps away from having a heart attack
right on site you said with team coffee
yeah i said it too
yeah i said it too yeah that's what i
picture a guy
in like a hanes t-shirt but he's wearing
it as an outer shirt but it's really an
understatement kick it on the working
man i don't understand what your problem
with the working man
i just picture a guy who's heaving as he
walks because it's a bit
as if you keep saying manly man the
coffee is for the manly man
why why it's for the hard-nosed female
reporter
okay lois lane is drinking coffee i
guarantee it
i guarantee lois lane is drinking coffee
by the way you know what else is great
about coffee
you dump a little jack d in it you dump
a little jim beam in it you dump a
little makers in it an irish coffee
nobody's adding liquor to tea unless
it's
like like a white cloth rt
you're insane a nice little toddy
sometimes i put tea in a toddy no
nuts come on pimp how are we doing on
time here
he always wants to go the phones folks
no i don't want to go to the phones i
just said how are we doing on time
but we're about ready to go to the
phones i hate to bring it to you
we we gave valid arguments here how many
11
861 votes pretty good turnout today
reads you read some of the comments see
people are going ice right away
uh that's another thing have tea will
can i before even look at tea will
settle your stomach
coffee will make you explode i
understand
you understand what i'm saying babe
coffee is going to help you evacuate
but is that a good thing look the the
pain in your stomach
is comes from the upset stomach that
comes from these drinks tea doesn't make
me almost [ __ ] my pants every time i
drink it
okay well sir micah
if you almost [ __ ] your pants every time
you drink coffee there's another thing
going on with
the 21 years i had tea for the first
time and immediately wanted to die
but coffee saved me if you say t go back
to england and remember who won the war
mark that that might be the winner that
might be a winner today
[Laughter]
all right coffee makes the [ __ ] smoother
and easier
all you're doing is getting [ __ ] related
comp comments look i love tea but ain't
nothing ever gonna beat the glorious
drink that is coffee
they call it tea baggie for a reason and
the sh and the shape of the tea bag is
well you know
tea okay people enjoy tea they rely on
coffee like a drug
i couldn't agree more uscipity
you enjoy a tea coffee is a drug you
never hear tea as a drug that's what i'm
saying you know people people
say i'm addicted to tea why is that
because
that if tea has more caffeine because it
would be the last thing
ever to be addicted to it's the lamest
addiction on
out of earth my addiction's out of
control i'm jonesing
quick boil some water and bring me a
variety of tea bags in a little chest
and a saucer don't forget a saucer i
need my uk audience coming through on
this
i need all my people out in europe all
my people out out there you got to come
through on this i hate both but t
doesn't smell like death that's funny
coffee is
professionals t is for hippies whoever
is arguing t
better hope your uk audience comes
through on this poll
tea is an old lady drink only bad
[ __ ] drink coffee
man if you choose tea how do you poop
uh any type of coffee makes me [ __ ]
myself so hard to the point where i
don't know if i'm going to make it out
alive
tea tastes like a dog's [ __ ] okay
jeez guys
these people do some of these other
things happening okay the pumpkin spice
latte is the
nah american decided this is 1776.
she is a good anytime drink coffee is
typically only good in the morning or
with desserts
that's a fair point only grandmas drink
tea
shout out grandmas
uh if you need coffee your help your
life is being held together via silly
string
and a low credit score there's nothing
wrong with that but it doesn't make it
better than t
just because you like chaos all right
good that that's our winner i'd say
that's good let's give it to morgan
follow morgan at
morgan doesn't care but it's spell
m-o-r-g-n
yeah m-o-r-g-n d-o-e-s
and t-n-t c-a-r-e
i gotta tell you i'm nervous because you
should be
because we're here in america and
america runs on coffee
you're you're gonna get crazy i know and
because all the young kids are addicted
to coffee no one drinks tea
i swear to god if there was a social
media app for a little bit of an
older subset of distinguished people i
would be demolished
you wouldn't i would be demolished
that's all old men drink is coffee it's
all women drink is coffee no it's all
kids drink nowadays unfortunately well
kids
pass on grass stay in school
i think we might be tied up now in
record i think it's 17 17 in one yeah
because the cream will always run cut
that out cut that out because i don't
know what order we're doing it in and i
don't want to go okay
sorry all right i this is this is this
is this is
you know i uh i was i was i was leaning
on
a global vote and it didn't come through
i didn't come through i mean
with starbucks and duncan and hort tim
hortons well what am i
does i can't compete with that i can't
compete with it i kept trying to tell
you that
i understand but kept insisting about
something about a result would sit down
at 3 p.m
i don't know what the hell are you
talking about you gotta start i gotta
start understanding though that
these results skew purely american no
that's not true
how so i took even with the countries
that drink tea you're not competing with
the countries that are doing
if i take a pinpoint i take a uk twitter
poll he's beating coffee
if you just pull if you just polish yeah
but but asia but you're looking at this
as if you just pulled
asia or england no but i'm saying like
the lion's share of people that follow
me are from the states
but if we really put it out to a real
global vote i really
think t is the powerhouse thing i mean
but this was a decisive victory sorry no
it's not a powerhouse
as kim pointed out it's been pointed out
to me before we even sat down in which i
didn't use this information because it
thought to be cheating t
in i mean coffee influences trade routes
to this day
not it's not one of the first things we
read we did
i don't remember that that's interesting
i don't know why you lost then but you
did and i won i'm the winner
i still love you buddy i love you too
you've been gloating a lot lately yeah
just take it easy
just what goes around comes around with
a little class yeah yeah like usually
in victory
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds